en pleine période du mythe ou où la
parole s'est libérée et la société
semble évoluer sur le respect des femmes
et l'égalité entre les sexes
internet semble être un îlot sur lequel
visiblement cette évolution a du mal à
s'opérer les messages comme tu es grosse
ténois cheval prendre les choses comme
ça un chiffre en témoignait selon
amnesty international toutes les 30
secondes sur twitter des femmes se font
insulter
franchement tu fais trop pitié va te
pendre
ce qui représente par an plus de 1,1
million de messages alors selon vous les
lois protège-t-elle assez contre les
cyber harcèlement
c'est incroyable alors voilà ce qu'on a
vu c'est complètement fou vous avez vu
les chiffres sont complètement dingue
c'est un chiffre alarmant qu'on voulait
vous donner aujourd'hui valérie moi je
trouve que c'est un chiffre absolument
terrible mais qui malheureusement il
suffit d'aller surfer sur twitter 30
secondes pour s'en rendre compte que il
n'est absolument pas surprenant
l'arsenal juridique existe l'arsenal
juridique et là il est suffisant
simplement il faut que les plateformes
jouent le jeu et le problème principal
problème c'est que les plateformes ne
jouent pas le jeu et qu'il est très
difficile de remonter et de récupérer
des ip etc
mais déjà été victime de cyber
harcèlement ici en plus d'être tous
assez inconnu vous géraldine l'année
dernière lors de la ferme enel dit
quesnel très très violent très violent
pour nous avec insultes oms à la limite
passe injures et menaces de mort
d'enlèvement de ma fille donc ça a été
très loin également d'autres face à la
structure on a déposé une main une main
courante et on a en a porté plainte
dernièrement avec les gilet jaune
beaucoup d' insulte haussier d'ailleurs
je remercie raymond qui m'avait bien
défendu aussi parce que ça a été aussi
très très très violent vous avez peur
des réseaux sociaux maintenant maman
aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est une
sorte de caniveaux à ciel ouvert je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de violence qui
a une sorte de racisme d'homophobie de
sexisme complètement déculpabiliser et
je pense que tant que ce sera anonyme
ce sera un danger public il faut à nous
elle déjà pas su déjouer des témoignages
je me suis fait menacer de mort
clairement sur le football
pourquoi parce que j'avais dit une
bêtise sur cavani
j'avais dit qu'il marque très peu de
buts ce que d'autres journalistes
collègues oui c'est une clairement de
conneries ce qu'on lui dit 10 millions
de fois j'ai dit j'ai dit une connerie
d'autres journalistes masculins avaient
dit la même chose ils se sont jamais
fait insulter jamais fait menacer
redmond est un moindre mal d'émissions
ensemble je me prenais des insultes des
menaces de mort constante et moi j'ai
fait l'erreur de ne pas porter plainte
parce que je me suis dit je vais laisser
passer
passer aujourd'hui trois ans après on
continue de me ressortir ça c'est
insupportable parce qu'on est des femmes
on est évidemment des cibles beaucoup
plus fragile de quitter tf1 c'était bon
c'est vrai que ferez-vous elle même topo
que c'est le géraldine gc ca ou sur les
mêmes thèmes on m'a raconté non au
moment de la ferme et neil les menaces
de mort sur mon fils inclus donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est bien moi c'est un
choc pour moi ben ce contrat mandat il
avait moins sur les sur les sites et
quand je suis allé dessus je me suis dit
comme juge et assassiné des gens c'est
pas possible pour de justifier un tel
déferlement de haine j'ai dû tuer
quelqu'un la seule chose que je trouve
un peu paradoxal c'est que les mêmes
gens qui râlent contre les teurses
contre les critiques et reçoit sur
internet se gargarise des compliments
qui reçoivent sur le même espace et
renvoie des coeurs nous en remercient
s'échoue pour les compliments faut
savoir où tu prends ton amer d'avoir pu
construire étant enfant et qu'on lui ont
dit on va le trouver là et on va le tuer
on va l'enlever c'est quand même pas
pareil qu'un likes ou un warren tweet
oui c'est alors dans le même